[Música]
un habitante de la República del Congo
contactó a los observadores de France 24
para denunciar las actividades de una
fundición instalada frente a su casa la
cual recicla baterías de plomo Él y su
colectivo de 187 vecinos afirman tener
problemas de salud relacionados con el
humo o con el hollín negro que recogió
Hace unos días en su jardín
estoy en mi casa y la fábrica está justo
detrás de mí solo nos espera un callejón
de 10 metros y eso no es todo a unos 50
metros sino menos hay un colegio privado
donde estudian entre 450 y 470 alumnos
justo debajo del tejado detrás de mí
está abierto
esas láminas no pueden impedir que el
humo salga el humo se dispersa entra en
las casas e incluso invade las aulas
alrededor de la fábrica la gente se
queja el aire es irrespirable
me mudé aquí cuatro o cinco meses
después toda mi familia se vio afectada
tuvimos casos de neumonía bronconeumonía
y bronquitis
desde que el prefecto del departamento
de cuilú visitó la zona en agosto de
2020 la fábrica realizó obras y a los
habitantes se les practicaron exámenes
médicos sin embargo la preocupación de
los residentes no se ha disipado todo lo
contrario a fecha de hoy aún no hemos
recibido los resultados de los exámenes
que le hicieron a la población no nos
quedamos con los brazos cruzados sabemos
que se dedican al reciclaje de plomo Así
que reunimos los recursos necesarios
para realizar análisis de sangre que
midan los niveles de plomo los análisis
muestran niveles de entre 250 y 150
microgramos de plomo en la sangre según
el investigador que consultamos estos
niveles son más que preocupantes a
partir de 500 microgramos en la sangre
puede haber síntomas más visibles la
fábrica Meza Congo por su parte afirma
que todo está en orden también nos
pusimos en contacto con la ministra del
medio ambiente de la República del Congo
y esta fue su respuesta hemos pedido
varias veces a esta fábrica que cumpla
con los requisitos ya había sido cerrada
por la falta de compromiso con las
reglas en vigor no dudaré en hacerlo
nuevamente
este es Newton
en Alaska estamos pasando por la escuela
vamos a ver lo cerca que está del río
aquí está
estas casas Están amenazadas por la
erosión se encuentran en Newton un
pueblo en la costa oeste de Alaska que
está sufriendo de lleno los efectos del
cambio climático como consecuencia el
pueblo simplemente desaparecerá los 400
indígenas yupic que vivían allí son una
de las primeras comunidades de
Norteamérica que han tenido que
reubicarse debido al aumento de las
temperaturas nuestro observadora ha
vivido en YouTube desde los 8 años
cuando era pequeña
todo el pueblo se está viendo afectado
por el derretimiento del permafrost
el permafrost es como una capa de hielo
que está bajo nuestros pies
pero se está derritiendo debido al
aumento de las temperaturas de la tierra
las casas Están construidas sobre el
suelo
el derretimiento del permafrost hace que
las casas sean inestables
las casas se ladean los cimientos y
agrietan
el océano se come en la tierra y la
erosiona
cuando yo era pequeña probablemente
había varios kilómetros entre la última
casa y el borde del agua
y cada año el agua se acerca un poco más
todos los años hay tormentas y la
situación es cada vez peor la última
tormenta de otoño causó muchos daños
algunas casas quedaron en ruinas otras
se inundaron al principio nadie quería
irse Yo decía que no quería mudarme pero
este era mi pueblo que aquí es donde
crecí pero ahora ya no podemos esperar
más porque ya no es seguro para nadie
vivir aquí
el pueblo decidió reubicarse hace más de
20 años pero la liberación de fondos
necesarios para construir el nuevo
pueblo de mert a unos 15 kilómetros de
Newton mucho tiempo las primeras
reubicaciones tuvieron lugar en 2019 y
más de la mitad de los habitantes
incluida nuestra observadora siguen
viviendo en newtoc Yo vivo en YouTube y
mis papás
es como si la mitad de mi familia
estuviera allá y la otra mitad acá
todavía hay que construir unas 40 casas
en mertar Vick
para los que aún estamos acá podamos
mudarnos
los que ya se mudaron están contentos
pero queremos estar juntos
porque ellos también sufren a su manera
acá tenemos una tienda una oficina de
correos y allá todavía no hay tienda
tienen que conducir 30 minutos para
llegar acá en noviembre de 2022 el
gobierno estadounidense destinó 25
millones de dólares a newtoc para ayudar
a financiar la reubicación al igual que
esta población alrededor de 70 de los
200 pueblos aborígenes de Alaska están
amenazados por la erosión las
inundaciones o el derretimiento del
permafrost
llegamos al final de los observadores
por esta semana si quieren escribirle a
nuestro equipo todos nuestros contactos
aparecen en pantalla envíenos sus fotos
y videos de aficionado y tal vez el
próximo observador de France 24 sea uno
de ustedes hasta pronto